en france avec une heure d'avancé sur
l'horaire prévu sans les embouteillages
monstre annonçée mickey accueilli
aujourd'hui ses premiers milliers de
visiteurs au coeur de son nouveau
royaume magique européen journée sans
histoire pour sensation américaine
sabine gornès mais voici aux adorateurs
de la petite souris une vraie famille
française de bulletins la première à
s'être présenté au guichet ce matin
grâce à mickey et la gagner la fausse
qualité et surtout un abonnement à vie
au royaume magique
comme elle des milliers d'anonymes venus
de toute l'europe ont fait le siège du
parc dès 6h ce matin
impatients de découvrir ce nouveau monde
à l'américaine gars venu au monde
magique d'euro disneyland pas plus
organisés que mickey une trentaine de
caisses des sourires on ouvre les portes
une heure avant et le tour est joué
225 francs l'entrée c'est cher mais le
rêve ça n'a pas de prix
peut-être on espère se rappeler un peu
l'objet
on a vu les états unis et voilà mais
c'est magnifique
donc on a voulu être là aujourd'hui pour
le premier jour on retrouve une enfant
pour une fois on est dans un autre monde
et tant pis pour les esprits chagrins
cette amérique de rêves colorés déguisé
peuplé de fées de personnages de dessins
animés les européens en redemande
dépaysement assuré par 29 attraction
très bien rodé ils étaient venus pour
les gosses ils sont au dessous de charme
subjugué par le souci du détail de la
machine disney ça me paraissait de 13
enfants tapent foire de pacotille je
trouve que c'est très bien même à
beaumont agréable mais moi je le vois
taille adulte
jean enchanté comme les organisateurs
qui affiche ce soir un sourire satisfait
mais refuse de communiquer le nombre
d'entrées par superstition ce soir
l'oncle picsou va faire ses comptes bien
réel en espérant que le bouche à oreille
marche à fond et que la petite souris
gagne son pari de 11 millions de
visiteurs par an